Name the 10 cities from their satellite images.
Three strikes and you lose.
Okay, it's European.
Looks Russian with water west.
St. Petersburg?
That's correct.
Okay.
That's just Table Mountain, Cape Town.
Correct.
Number three?
San Francisco.
You can see the Golden Gate Bridge.
Yeah.
Wow, there's a lot of parks.
Looks kind of British.
Water east.
Is it Newcastle?
It is not Newcastle.
Water east, that's right on the ocean with a big port.
Oh, is it Dublin?
Yes.
Okay.
There's water on both sides with a river coming through the middle.
Looks European.
Why does it look so...
Okay, it kind of looks like Amsterdam, but it's not Amsterdam.
Okay.
Oh, I see the bridge going to...
Is it Copenhagen?
Yes.
I see the little tunnel bridge thing that's going to Sweden.
That's Bangkok.
Yes.
You can see all the patties.
Okay, next one.
Rio de Janeiro.
You can see the Copacabana Beach.
Okay, this one is number eight.
Desert City.
Looks like Arabic-ish.
Some sort of wadi on the southwest.
Ocean on the east.
Not many options this could be.
Tunis?
Yeah.
Okay, Tunis-Tunisia.
I was going to say, you've been to Tunisia, so you should know that one.
Next one, number nine.
Water west, very dense.
Looks Southeast Asian.
Wow, it's so dense.
Is it Manila?
Yeah.
Okay.
Ooh, the pressure.
Yeah, okay, so here's the last one.
That's Venice.
Yeah, that was an easy last one.
Okay.